[Music]
the big challenge that we have in the
university was to factor first factor
was the absolute sense of our systems
really difficult to upgrade and the
second one was the speed or they have no
possibility to grow up in our data
center on-premise with IBM cloud
solutions and VMware solution which
solves both problems our solution is
based on our hybrid cloud we are using
80% public cloud and 20% private cloud
and our spectating is to go for the next
five years trying to arrive to the 90
percent almost everything will be in the
public cloud IBM cloud vien were
solution provided us the flexibility to
move servers and virtual machines around
the world around the different data
centers with speed and half for delivery
our solution using NSX with vSphere
provided to our university flexibility
and scalability and this point of
security that we want to all to achieve
a spectrum data protest and the spittoon
protect are two of the functionalities
that you have in your IBN cloud on top
of your infrastructure on top of your
systems to protect them in the current
way this is another point y which is IBN
cloud vien were a really good
relationship that permits us to move our
virtual machine with a simple leaf and
safe for a CIO was me that means that
I'm absolutely happy and I'm sleeping
much more secure
[Music]